Hey,
what's going on in his bill?
Burn.
It's time for the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
November six,
2017 what's going on?
How are you?
How are you doing?
No,
really,
seriously.
Are you okay?
I've been thinking about you.
Is there anything worse when you don't want someone to like,
you know,
if you don't want to talk about your fucking troubles and then there's that
overly caring person in your life that notices them and yet they're like,
you know,
what's,
what's going on with the,
Oh,
I'm cool.
I'm good.
No,
seriously.
You seem there's just picking up something on your energy.
Is it,
what do you even fucking Star Trek.
Yeah,
he read my mind,
you know?
I mean,
you're right.
I don't need you was a non fucking,
uh,
psychiatrist walking around my brain.
Everybody thinks they're a fucking qualified because they watched a couple
episodes of Dr Phil and he makes it look so easy for the simple fact that the
man does not give a shit.
Okay.
He's here for one reason only.
All right.
It's for the Ou is after the show.
You know,
that's why he has that fucking angry.
Ever seen a guy helping more people with such like a fucking angry look on his
face.
Um,
you know,
I got the chief's fucking cowboys game on in the background.
How many times does this special team fuck up a free lunch when the punch or
kicks it right down to the one yard line?
Eh,
they're just the worst.
The guy fucking did it through.
Everybody wants to be the guy that does it and then they fucking fumbled the
ball into the end zone.
And what happens?
The punter takes the head and in,
rather than him having a 41 yard fucking average for the game,
it moves down to 38 right?
And the second day see that three.
All of a sudden they want to move you to another team.
Nobody ain't nobody ever looks at the nameless [inaudible] that run down the
fucking field,
the wedge breakers,
all of them,
right?
The guys that nobody has talked about since John Madden,
stop announcing games.
They'd go down there and consistently fuck that play up.
Uh,
this has nothing to do with NFL.
Special teams to says nothing to do with people asking me,
how are you doing?
Is Everything good?
You look good.
But I sense of sadness.
It's just like,
can you just
chicken?
You just fucking let me sit here.
All right,
wait,
I'm ready to talk about this.
It's like this isn't yours to talk about,
right.
Anyways.
Um,
can I say anyways,
one more fucking time?
My last podcast I left you,
I was at the Surf Ball run,
right?
Chantilly lace Santa Brady face a bone.
Right.
Hanging down or we're wig to land,
a walk and the
giggling I was there,
make the world go pow.
Wow.
Wow,
wow.
And the next day I was flying air choice one
okay.
To Chicago.
And then I was taking another puddle jumper up to 'em.
What the hell was it?
Milwaukee.
Right.
So me and Dean del Rey,
we show up.
We had like the greatest fucking night ever.
We stayed at this hotel that was designed by Frank Lloyd Webber.
Amazing hotel.
So we drive up to the airport,
the airport,
the Mason City Airport.
It's just the quiet one of the greatest thing ever.
I want to,
I'm going to upload some pictures.
You walk in this,
this probably 12 chairs for people in the waiting room and you go through this
little security area.
I love little airports,
little mom and pop airports.
I get up there at dean checks in all good.
I go to check in,
I'm on the nine 25 I land in Chicago O'hare.
I have a little low of fun,
you know,
a little layover and then I'm going to go up to a,
then I'm going to go up to the uh,
you know,
up to Milwaukee,
right for my seven what?
I thought it was a seven 30 show turned out it was at seven so I get in there
and the lady behind the counter goes,
a,
you're not flying until five 25 and I was like,
ah,
that is impossible.
I won't be.
And you know,
I won't be in Milwaukee and time for my show.
She goes,
well,
according to this,
you're on the five 25.
I go,
all right,
well,
is there room on the nine 25 so I can switch flights?
She goes,
no,
I'm sorry,
that's sold out.
So immediately,
you know,
meet with my temper.
I go,
oh,
so what?
So what?
That one sold out so you bump me to the next flight and she just,
she just stuck her hand out.
Like when your dad used to say cooling,
right?
She just stuck her hand out.
She just goes,
hey,
we don't do that here.
All right.
Starts fucking giving me shit back and starts saying that I screwed up.
I mean,
what do you mean ice?
How do you know what I see?
I got a confirmation number,
I got all this type of stuff and she goes,
we don't do that tag.
Okay,
so you guys never mess up.
You never mess up.
This is on me.
My travel agent never screws up.
Right?
And we're going back and forth,
back and forth,
and she starts fucking yelling at me and I'm,
you know,
I'm keeping my voice.
I'm definitely,
you know,
definitely on my toes,
but I'm not yelling,
but she's yelling at me or raising her voice.
And finally I just said to her,
I said,
lady,
why are you yelling at me?
Okay,
I'm the one who's getting screwed here.
Your shift ends at whatever time it ends.
It's no skin off your back.
I'm not yelling,
I'm not swearing.
Why you swearing?
Right?
I'm not yelling.
Why are you yelling at me?
She got all fucking pissed and I was just like,
Jesus Christ.
I thought people were friendly and Iowa.
That's what I heard.
Right?
So now I have to get a fucking rental car and I have to drive from clear lake.
You know,
I,
my people up up,
up,
I've,
everybody's trying to figure out what the fuck's going on.
So now I've got to rent up.
I got to rent up God damn car and clear Lake Iowa and I have to drive from clear
Lake Iowa all the way to Milwaukee,
which is going to be nothing but fucking cow pastures.
You know what I mean?
I'll tell you what's amazing is that anybody could crash and die in Iowa.
That's what I took away from this fucking drive because all I see is it's just a
giant,
it's just a giant field,
you know?
Sorry.
Anyways,
so I call it my travel agent.
We go to fucking figure it out.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what happened,
but it turns out it was somewhere on my end.
Somebody fucked up.
So I walked up to the lady and I said,
listen,
I apologize.
I actually apologized to her and just said it was,
it was somebody on my end,
where can I get the rental car?
And then I just had to fucking deal with that shit.
And the stupid thing said it was a five hour something minute drive and I just
got in the fucking car and drove late 80 85 the entire way.
I averaged 79 miles an hour.
That was with no stops.
No,
no getting gas.
But you know,
whenever a truck gets in the left lane and tries to pass up a hill,
that fucks the next 20 minutes of your life up,
you know?
But,
uh,
anyways,
I ended up making it there.
My apologies to the lady,
you know,
who could have been a little nicer.
You know,
I think I brought it out of her.
All right.
But I,
I will tell you this.
Okay.
You know,
people tell me how friendly everybody is an Iowa until you question what it is
they're doing.
Then all of a sudden they get their backs up or I met one of the few angry
people out there,
I dunno.
Slipknots from Iowa.
That's not exactly happy go lucky music is it.
Um,
so I fucking drove all the way into Milwaukee like a maniac because I wanted to
get to my favorite hotel in the United States of America.
Uh,
which is the Pfister hotel.
I swear to God.
It's called the Pfister.
It's the last name of this family.
It's spelled p.
If you are ever in Milwaukee,
that is where you stay.
You stay at the Pfister.
All right.
It was Guido Pfister had the idea for it and his kid came through with it,
you know,
this was the 18 hundreds when his last name was Pfister.
All right.
Somehow they said they were German,
but his first name is Guido.
I mean is it Pfiester?
All I know is as far as I know,
I think fisting had died down in the 18 hundreds,
so you could have that as a a a last name.
But I,
I believe
enrollment times according to like movies,
movies like Culligan,
Leah,
yeah,
that was going on.
But now with all this sexual harassment and evidently all these fucking lunatic
perverts slash rapist,
um,
in Hollywood,
I love that they're acting like this is specific to Hollywood.
That's something they do all the time.
Like if there's like an NFL player that gets busted for domestic violence,
they go,
what is with these athletes beating women?
And it's like it,
that's not it.
This is just a microcosm of the,
so just a little sample of humanity.
I would s I would actually be willing,
be willing to bet that there's just as many plumbers out there that get accused
of domestic violence as football players or whatever.
It's just that plumbers don't sell out football stadiums.
There's not a giant plumber stadium to see,
you know,
a first ballot hall of fame plumber,
a plumber sink.
So nobody pays attention.
So everybody gets to act like,
oh,
it's,
it's going on.
It's in Hollywood.
It's,
it's,
it's over here.
Like they always notice what people on television at doing,
you know,
let me look at Bill Clinton.
I mean,
you know,
okay,
this guy comes on a fucking fern.
He's blown a load on a dress,
which is standard.
I guess that's more,
that's more pedestrian place for your,
just end up,
you know,
if you're going to sit there in court,
and your lawyer is going to be going,
all right,
this is going to be a little bit of an embarrassing day for you buddy.
Uh,
they're gonna bring your ges in and,
you know,
but it's on a dress.
So,
uh,
I'm willing to bet that a number of people
you know,
that are in the jury at some point have splurged on a dress,
at very least one of their own t shirts.
You know,
let's not forget about tube socks,
but that,
you know,
that goes without saying,
right.
It's,
but then,
you know,
if you're on trial and you,
you did it into a plant,
you know,
that's a little weird.
A plant is different than,
you know,
if you fucked outside cause then you're just outside.
But a plant is just really specific.
Yeah.
I thought Hollywood was green.
I thought they gave a shit about the environment anyways.
Um,
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
So yeah,
it's,
it's an unbelievable,
like this fucking hotel.
You,
you could've shot the shining in there.
I mean that in a good way.
Not in a creepy way,
because as creepy as that movie is,
that is a beautiful hotel.
And,
um,
it's basically,
I'll upload some pictures of that too,
but it's like literally something that Stanley Kubrick could have filmed one of
his masterpieces in.
And,
uh,
also they have the greatest sickest death defying steam room,
in country.
I know all this is really sonic bad Pfister's steam room.
Trust me,
it's all above board.
Uh,
it's just if you go there,
this is how it works.
The steam comes on for seven minutes.
You're going to be in there with you for 20 minutes or half hour.
If you get the half hour one,
it comes on for seven minutes,
okay?
And it's literally like a steam pipe broke.
And uh,
I had to get underneath the towel because what you want to do is just let all
that steam come in.
You got to tough it out for seven minutes.
All right?
Because it's not going to come on again until the final seven.
If you've got the 30 minute one 20 minutes,
it never comes on again.
So as hot as it gets,
you've got to know that that steam has to last for the entire time that you're
in there and there's a shower does like you've got your own private place and
there's a shower down the end of it.
So this the first day I went in there,
I fucking,
I opened the window a little bit because I couldn't take it anymore.
And then I closed it.
When it started to die down,
I realized that let all the steam out and then four minutes later it was
borderline chili in this.
I was like,
fuck,
I screwed it up.
All right,
so tomorrow when I get there,
I'm just going to tough to shut out.
Right.
And I was under a towel like four and a half minutes in,
literally going,
ah,
fuck,
fuck.
And I just couldn't take it anymore.
So I was like,
don't open the window,
run to the other side and turn on the shower.
Right.
It's like an overhead shower and you have it on cold.
And I went over there and it was like half a degree,
not as hot,
like the steam.
I've ran by the steam thing and my fucking legs felt like,
I actually understand now what it feels like initially when you're on fire
because you know what you want to do,
but she can't do it because you're too busy hopping up and down.
So I'm literally hopping up and down with an,
I want to turn on the shower,
but I,
I had to like,
I was reacting to the penguin.
Ha ha ha,
fuck eh,
fuck.
And the handle was right there.
And I just kept reaching down pat and get my legs rather than just reaching over
and turn it on the thing.
So finally I had to block out the pain for like 0.2 seconds,
reach over and turn on the fucking thing.
And of course the last person that was in there left it on hot after,
you know,
if the steam was over and they took a hot shower.
So it came out hot and I was like,
fuck,
fuck.
Turn it back down to get it down to cold.
And I just stood there for the final three and a half minutes doing it is no
joke.
And uh,
the half hour was done.
Like I walked out of that thing and I was like breathing heavy.
I was coming out of like,
uh,
like coming out.
I was fucking all red,
right?
So I go out into the way,
you know,
and then you cool off for like 15 minutes and you're just sitting there and you
want,
you're not thinking about anything.
You just sit in there totally relaxed.
You feel fucking amazing.
MMM.
Wow.
In the back of your head going like a,
you know,
I don't know if that was healthy or not.
Right.
So then I would go out of the steam room,
right?
The lady comes back and gets you.
And,
um,
I go to the waiting room and Bartolik is already there and he just looks at me
and he starts laughing,
right?
Cause I'm all fucking red.
And I got the shaved head.
He goes,
dude,
you look like the flash.
Which is hilarious because when I looked at myself in the mirror,
I mumbled out loud,
like I look like if Hellboy and Jason Vorhees had a kid,
is that the name of the guy from fucking Friday the 13th?
Uh,
when he,
you know,
when he comes up out of the lake now when he pulls the mask upper right.
I'm not that ugly,
but I'm just saying.
Um,
and we just sat there just like drinking water and everything.
MMM.
You know,
I gotta be honest with you two days in a row at doing that,
the next night I had two shows at the Riverside theater.
Um,
just a magical fucking place that is,
and the,
the comedy crowds in Milwaukee or there,
they're unbelievable.
I cannot say enough good things about that city.
It might be my favorite city in the country.
Um,
and uh,
I had two shows and like after,
like I got three quarters the way through my first show and I was feeling like
to hydrate it.
Like I was like,
after two days of that level of intensity,
I was like,
uh,
I really should have crushed a bunch of waters here,
you know,
versus he told me he drank a Gatorade was talking about electrolytes,
and he's like,
you gotta do that,
get the electrolytes going.
And I vaguely remember seeing on the Internet that electrolytes really isn't a
thing.
That's just something that Gatorade came up with.
Solon,
let me look this up.
I mean,
I don't want to challenge Paul versus medical degree,
but um,
I don't know if our electrolytes,
electrolytes,
that thing here
are a Lek troll lights.
Oh,
I fucked you want,
there's a y in there.
There it is.
Our electrolytes real.
All right.
Now there's all kinds of electrolytes,
but the most important ones are sodium chloride,
potassium.
Oh,
they are real.
I thought that that was like something like,
you know,
rather than than when it's not a diamond.
They call it a diet.
Ml.
You genuine diann mills.
Like what?
What the fuck is it Diane smell?
Well,
it's like a diamond except it's not worth anything.
Oh,
I'd like one of those.
I thought an electrolyte is what the F is an electrolyte.
Is Gatorade the real deal?
All right.
Everybody loves Gatorade,
so let's talk about if it's fluff or actually good for you.
All you hear about is rehydrate this and electrolyte.
That is it for real.
Your body has a balance and has an ionic solution.
Boring term.
Don't worry about it.
I want to know what it is.
As an eye has weight and has ionic solutions called electrolytes to keep your
body muscles and nerves functioning properly.
Your kidneys exists to help keep your body in balance by regulating the fluids
and electrolytes in your body.
Yeah,
they filter,
they filter the fluids in your body.
Right?
I thought it was just literally the liquids that you ingest.
MMM.
Isn't it unbelievable that I don't know how to fucking body works.
I mean,
not that you guys think I'm smart.
I know you know what,
that I'm dumb.
But you would think that if you would know how that would work,
right?
Your kidneys make,
Oh God,
I hate this word.
You Kitty's make p I hate when adults say p unless they're talking to a child.
Like,
Do you have to go pee pee when an adult says,
I have to pee,
I can't handle it.
All right,
I got to go to the bathroom.
Just say that.
All right.
Your kidneys make you know piss.
That's disgusting.
They'll pissed.
Pissed.
Pisses crest P is like,
you know,
you got to walk it off.
When an adult says that to your names.
Have you ever heard a guy say that to you?
Hey,
can you pull over here?
I have to pee.
I mean,
he might as well just given you like a back rub.
Oh,
maybe it's not that bad.
Anyways,
they basically filter your blood so you can get rid of waste products like urea
and ammonia.
Ammonia.
Somebody trying to kill me.
The fuck did I get some ammonia?
I really need to know how this shit works.
Should I,
as I'm heading into my fifties,
by the way,
uh,
drive from my fifties,
I'm not going to drink until I'm 60.
I've decided that I've made that decision.
I know,
I know.
I'll never make it anyway.
So when you are dehydrated,
your kidneys make your p as concentrated as possible to keep water in the body.
Uh,
okay.
What does that mean?
When you are well hydrated,
your kidneys let more water leave with the waste.
Now there's all kinds of electrolytes,
but the most important ones are sodium chloride,
potassium,
bio,
carbonate,
calcium right here.
This is me in high school.
I'm not passing this class.
The second link,
the teacher's writing this and the sodium chloride,
potassium stop writing.
Biocarbon Ada that's over and phosphate.
You kidneys has specific transporters to regulate the concentrations of each of
these electrolytes in your blood.
You know what I'm going to ask Paul tonight.
I am going to ask him,
I'm going to set them up.
I'm going to say,
Paul,
did you really feel better drinking the Gatorade afterward?
He's going to be like absolutely a thousand percent.
And I said,
what does it do?
Replace his,
what is his or her place?
And he's going to say electrolytes and I'm going to say Paul,
what are electrolytes?
And I guarantee you there's no fucking way he's going to be like,
you know,
it's the uh,
it's the shit in your uh,
your system.
Yeah.
So you don't get like leg cramps immediately have to go to the NFL and think
about people like legs cramp it up.
That tends to be a name for that cause I do that all the time.
Like you can,
you can give an informed answer while still not knowing what the fuck you're
saying.
It's like what's his face?
Tony Romo said this guy has a high football acumens and I'm like,
what the hell is that?
The fuck is a high football acument an acumen is having good judgment and quick,
I don't know,
quick decision making in a particular field.
So it's kind of insulting,
you know what I mean?
He's saying like,
you know,
he could be still saying this guy's a fucking moron,
but if you get them on the football field,
like he knows this shit.
He's like the rain man when he gets out there.
Right.
So now that he said a high football aq human,
all the mouth breathers at watch sports like myself,
can you understand [inaudible] there's like,
I don't know what the word is.
Like you're the rhythm,
but you know where to place that word without actually knowing it,
without being able to give a definition.
The only reason why I could give a definition because I looked it up cause I
never heard it because I want to make a joke on Twitter about it.
Right?
Like don't,
it's his fucking accurate kid.
You're going to start hearing that in sports bars and then you can,
you can replace high football.
You can just any subject,
he has a high gardening aq human without ever looking up at acumen.
You know,
you could just just keep replacing the,
the uh,
whatever the,
what is it,
the subject.
He has a high serial killer,
a acumen.
So I feel electrolyte is one of those words where you just keep watching the
Gatorade commercial and it's telling you that it's,
it's,
it's helping to replace electrolytes and uh,
you know,
and then enough time do you got like,
yeah.
You know,
you're just repeating the advertising.
what the fuck it means.
Like I know that Gatorade is thirsty for that deep down body thirst.
I don't know what thirst aid is.
It's aiding your thirst
or is that just all one word?
Gatorade,
Thursday.
You know,
you like when rappers do that and when they want to make something rhyme and
they'll just take the,
the,
the suffix of another word and they just do fucking 10 words in a row like that.
And you go,
just want to be like,
I always want to be all white in that moment.
Like excuse me,
Mister Mc.
Those aren't words.
You're,
you're inventing words.
It's weird cause I know what they mean.
But those aren't words.
You will not get credit for that rap.
I'm sorry.
Well,
not in my Culdesac Ywam.
Well that's the reason to get angry.
Um,
anyways,
let's finish this.
This is actually fucking interesting to me
how much,
I don't know.
Your kidneys have a specific transporters to regulate the concentration of each
of these electrolytes in your blood when you work out,
you sweat.
Yup.
Four years of college taught me that,
um,
ms kids trying to be funny.
When you work out,
you sweat.
When you sweat,
you lose fluids and electrolytes,
especially slow sodium and chloride,
which is why your sweat tastes salty.
Uh,
now when you're lacking fluids and electrolytes,
your muscle suffer.
Yeah.
And your point,
yeah.
It's just basically like a car leaking oil.
Um,
let's talk about why Gatorade or any sports drink works water.
We'll get into your bloodstream faster when it's part of Gatorade because
waterflows follows electrolytes.
Skate arrayed has electrolytes,
so it has salt and shit in there.
Chloride,
potassium,
I know potassiums and like a bananas,
but I thought chloride was like some shit that either cleans your clothes or a,
it sounds too much like chlorine,
like that.
Seems like that would be poisonous.
Calcium,
calcium deposits on your teeth.
I know our calcium is calcium is in like fucking broccoli phosphate.
Like fuck.
I would think phosphate is like,
you know when you turn the car on your garage,
carbon dioxide and phosphate get into your system.
Well actually a high,
a two high level of any of these electrolytes could prove fatal.
Theoretically what's your body is,
is a symphony of balance.
I'm not passing this class,
uh,
when you work out.
All right,
so I think I kind of know what the fuck this shit is.
While I guess,
I guess it's true.
I didn't think it was
Jesus.
Wasn't that a long,
boring trip down to fucking nowhere.
Anyways,
so I get to Milwaukee,
I finally got to see the bronze fonts.
You know,
pappy days took place there.
I took a picture that I'm going to tweet out later today and Hava Richie and
Fonzie of finally back together again before we comment on Twitter goes,
Huh?
Yeah,
you fucking look like Ralph mouth.
I'd say more Ralph,
myself laughing my ass off by myself at my own joke that I wrote with my thumbs.
Um,
I finally went to the Harley Davidson Museum.
Jesus Christ.
You got to do that.
This is how great Milwaukee is.
I actually told people in Milwaukee that I wasn't going to tell people how great
he is,
but I kind of have to because it's fucking amazing because most people won't
listen anyways,
right.
All the Yolo do shoes.
You know,
they're going to go to Chicago,
maybe,
you know,
go to a cubs game,
that popped collar or whatever the fuck it is.
They do.
But then they're going to go to the,
they're gonna go to the party cities.
If you're in your 20s,
you're not going to Milwaukee.
Right.
I don't know what they do.
Whenever these fucking Djs play,
that's where they come and they go on to Vegas,
they go into Miami,
they're going to one of those places,
right,
with a base.
Never stops.
Bam.
Now,
now,
now
they had the Harley Davidson Museum.
They have my favorite fucking beer.
Miller,
the Miller brewery company is right there.
You can take a tour of it.
I wish I was drinking.
I would have done that because they get you like,
you know,
borderline shit faced before you leave.
And uh,
they got the river walk.
Next time I go out there,
I'm going out there during the s or in the summer.
Milwaukee is basically Chicago with like,
you know,
fucking half the population.
Um,
all the same stuff,
all the same great views,
the traffic.
I love it.
Um,
then I,
oh Brian,
a Monday morning,
a Photoshop gentlemen is from out that way and he fucking let us know about some
spots to go to.
And it was a,
he told us about this place,
Van Guard,
which makes these fucking brats and sausages and they were just next level.
They were the best sauce I've ever had.
All right.
To keep with the homo erotic theme of this podcast,
right?
We had the Pfister hotel,
we had a steam room,
and now I'm talking about sausage
and were this is my favorite place to go.
So,
hey,
maybe I'll come out like Kevin Spacey and just gonna make sure I,
uh,
you know,
Kenny,
again this,
this,
this is a very thin fucking line to walk there with a comedy exists that at the
end of the day,
you know,
it's just Jesus fucking Christ.
What is going on?
Um,
anyways,
where else?
What else do I want to talk about?
Ah,
yeah.
So we just had the best time and me Versie in Barton,
it just kept saying that like,
I fucking love this city.
City is awesome.
And I don't say it's about a lot of places,
but I,
that's,
I could literally live there.
My big fucking thing though is,
is I'm just really sick of living where my sports teams aren't.
You know,
I've been behind enemy lines as far as being a sports fan goes since 1995.
And
you know,
recently I went back to Boston.
I remember I went back with a fuck that I think went to a Bruins game or
something.
Yeah.
I went to a Bruins game.
That's right.
I was,
I did one day on a,
uh,
so when I did well,
I did one day in a movie.
I can't remember.
I can't remember the fuck I was there.
I went there during hockey season.
That's what I remember.
And,
uh,
I went to a Bruins game and I'll never forget,
I looked out the hotel window and all I saw was this sea of Bruins jerseys.
And I was just like,
oh my God,
if I forget what this feels like,
and I,
that's the one thing that I don't know.
That would be the only thing star other than,
I don't know if I could exist in this business,
live in there in Milwaukee.
But,
uh,
I don't know.
It's fucking fresh air.
I like it.
I fuck,
I don't know why.
I have no idea.
All right.
But we get it.
We get it.
All right,
let's read a little bit of advertising here for,
um,
oh,
you know what?
Fuck that.
Let's talk about the fucking Iowa Hawkeyes beating the fucking shit of the Ohio
state buckeyes.
What happened?
The buck,
I said that huge win last week against Penn state.
I saw Jay lightheaded at the all things comedy fucking festival,
and the man was literally floating.
Okay.
Floating across the Goddamn Room.
The man simply could not believe it.
Couldn't believe as good fortunes.
He was saying that was probably the most impressive win of the college football
season.
And you would be very hard pressed to come up with an argument different to
different,
you know?
Yeah.
And then a week fucking later they absolutely shit the bed again.
I mean,
ain't got that shit kicked out of them.
If they didn't do that dumb fake punt,
whatever the hell that partner was doing,
they would have been like 55 17 they just shut them down in the second half.
It was a,
it was unbelievable.
And then Penn state loses again toe.
So what does that mean?
What does that mean?
Meanwhile?
Was Constance fucking undefeated and everybody's going to be like,
well,
there's fucking nobody.
There's nobody on the west.
We got Michigan,
we've got a house day,
we got fucker Michigan State,
we got Penn state.
So I great,
well you know what,
they got out west to get the fucking Iowa Hawkeyes.
How cool did that stadium look?
MMM,
whenever I watch Iowa,
right.
Play football.
I don't know why.
I always think back when I liked Iowa when I was a kid because there was a
running back Ronnie Harmon that I really liked and I brought it up to this guy
when I was on the plane,
uh,
taking the puddle jumper over and he brought up how he fucking fumbled four
times in a rose bowl or some shit.
And I had no idea that,
I didn't even know that happened.
And then there was this whole fucking scandal trying to say that,
that he fixed the game cause he'd like never fumbled ever.
And then he fumbled four times in the first half.
I don't know,
maybe it was just a bad time to have a bad game,
but I never knew that about him.
But he had a great NFL career.
Okay.
Rush by like 8,500 yards,
almost 10,000 yards,
um,
played like 11 years or something like that.
Uh,
I dunno.
Anyways,
I'm getting off the beaten track.
Hey,
let's,
let's do a little advertising here.
All right,
it's time.
Oh,
here we go.
All Zip.
Are you hiring well?
Are you,
do you know where to post your job to find the best candidates?
With Ziprecruiter,
you can post your job to over 100 of the web's leading job with just one click.
So you can rest easy knowing your job is being seen by the right candidates.
Then zip
puts its smart matching technology to work actively notifying qualified
candidates about your job within minutes of posting so you can receive the best
possible matches.
You can get a headstart on the interview process by adding screening questions
to your job to post wait till your job post to help identify the most qualified
candidates so you don't have to waste your time sorting through a stack of
resumes to find the perfect fit.
No wonder 80% of employers who post on Ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
through the site.
And just one day and the easy to use Zip Dash Cook Dashboard
lets you manage your hiring process from start to finish all in one place.
Find out today why ZipRecruiter has been used by growing businesses of all sizes
and indices to find the most qualified job candidates with immediate results.
And right now my listeners can post jobs on zip
for free.
That's right free.
Just go to ziprecruiter.com/birth that's ziprecruiter.com/bar one more time.
Hey,
try it for free.
Go to ziprecruiter.com/burp sorry I can't keep doing different voices.
I got to do a show here tonight.
I'm going to fucking blow up my voice here.
Oh my God.
Dollar Shave Club.
Do they have a high shave and an acumen?
Kid,
you've heard me talk about the amazing shape I get from dollar shave club races,
especially when I use the Dr Covey's easy shave butter.
Well,
I'm here to tell you I'm never going to give up my membership.
They're going to have to pry it from my cold,
dead fucking fingers.
In fact,
I'm adding even more dollar shave club products to my daily routine.
Dollar Shave Club makes products for your hair,
your face,
your skin,
your shower,
your dog,
your wife,
your cousin that you fucking everything you need.
They have me looking and feeling amazing and it's all their own original stuff.
They only use the finest premium ingredients and they deliver it to you just
like they do their racist.
That means no more annoying trips to the fucking store cruising up and down the
aisles.
Right.
Seeing the old people looking for shit for old people,
just reminding you that you're going to die someday.
I use dollar shave club for almost everything do I razors,
body cleansers,
Hair Gel.
I don't use the hair gel.
I don't have any here.
What am I fucking Gel in?
My pubes obey and yes,
even the butt wipes and that was a great time to give dollar shave club a try.
You can try,
you can get your first month of their amazing best razor and with travel sized
versions of the shave butter body cleanser.
And yes,
even the butt wipes just for $5 and the after that replacement cartridges ship
just for a few bucks a month.
It's the dollar shave club static kit.
Get yours for just $5 exclusively@dollarshaveclub.com slash bird that's dollar
shave club.com/bar and lastly,
but not leastly.
Um,
stamps.com everybody stamps saved you time and money,
uh,
which you need to grow your business.
Evidently I can mail any letter,
any package,
just using my computer and printer and the mailman comes and picks it up.
Avoid the hassle,
man of going to the post office and mailing everything from postcards to
envelopes.
Oh,
avoid the hassle of going to the post office and mail everything from postcards
and envelopes to packages,
domestic or international,
right from your own goddamn house.
Create your stamps.com create your stamps account in minutes online with no
equipment to lease and no longterm commitments.
Click print mail and you're done.
Unlike the post office stamps.com never closes.
Print postage for letters or packages at your convenience.
24 zone.
Um,
I use stamps.com anytime I'm a sending my posters up and right now I'm in a
moron if I can figure it out.
So can you,
and right now you can enjoy stamps.com servers with a special offer that
includes a four week trial plus postage and a digital scale without longterm
commitments.
We ain't go where nowhere go to stamps.com click on the
microphone@thetopofthehomepageandtypeinbirththatstampsdotcomandtobarstamps.com.
Never go to the post office again.
MMM.
Oh that's right.
I got to promote this.
I am going to be in New York City.
Okay.
And now we'll be doing a special secret top secret show.
Then I'm not even promoting on my website.
I'm just promoting here on my podcast.
Unless of course we don't sell the place out,
then we'll open it up to everybody else.
But this,
this is your reward for listening to my podcast.
All right,
I'm going to be at a new comedy club that's in New York City.
It's called the west side comedy club.
And,
um,
you can make a guess.
You can get tickets at their website,
which is w they're not,
they're not live yet,
so relax.
All right.
They're going to go live Monday,
November six,
which should be the day you're listening to this,
even though I'm taping it on the fifth,
Monday,
November 6th at noon eastern time.
MMM.
And I will be performing at the West Side Comedy Club,
uh,
on
Sunday,
November 12th.
So tickets go on sale Monday,
November 6th.
Um,
and
the show is at eight o'clock.
It's Sunday,
November 12th at the West Side Comedy Club,
which is at two oh one west 75th street.
MMM.
And I think that's it.
All right.
So
check that out.
And so perfect size place.
It looks awesome.
It's right next to the beacon theater.
It's a little 100 seat thing.
I'm going to doing about 40,
45 minutes,
trying out some new shit.
Fucking around,
having a good time.
Um,
you know,
keeping the hour tight.
Uh,
and that's it.
It's a couple,
a friends of mine that are owning and running the club from my days.
Way Back.
We're going back to like the Boston Comedy Club in that type of shit.
Um,
so anyways,
uh,
check that out if you've got a chance.
And is that everything that I want to talk about?
I think so.
Can we go into the,
uh,
questions for the week?
How long into this podcast?
Oh,
39 minutes.
Okay.
That's perfect.
That is perfect.
I think I could run my mouth for another.
Do.
What the fuck was Lsu doing against Alabama?
I know it's Alabama because they drop more goddamn passes that she had a
highlight reel of him fucking up passes blowing opportunities
a day I go to be asking myself,
how good is the Alabama Crimson tide considering they're playing in a much
weaker c than we've seen in years?
Who knows?
But I'll tell you why they're great.
Because even though that they were winning easily against Lsu for the most,
for most of the game,
um,
Nick Saban was still getting pissed,
screaming and yelling.
He knows,
he knows.
He sees an updraft passes.
He's like,
well,
if they caught that and they caught that,
you know,
this game could be this.
Okay.
You don't get credit because they dropped it.
You get credited.
If you knock it down,
then he feels like we're playing good defense.
That is why that is why that guy's the shit.
Um,
but it will be interesting to see because a few weeks ago it looked like Penn
state was world beaters.
Now they've lost two in a row.
Ohio state looked like they were coming on and then they got the live in shit.
They got the living there was alive shit in them and it was kicked out of them.
They got to feel a lot lighter that after this,
this past weekend.
Um,
okay.
All right.
Let's,
uh,
let's do it.
A little questions here for the rest of the podcasts are plastic surgery.
All right,
Bill,
I watched your specials every single day.
Jay's is to take a break.
I appreciate it.
But you know,
you know,
at some point you're gonna start hating me and it's not going to be my fault.
Um,
all right.
I have a wonderful time and I laugh to the jokes as if I've seen them for the
first time.
I live in China and youtube is a bitch here.
Lol.
Wow.
The Fuck Outta here.
That's amazing.
Good luck waiting for your new
stuck.
S t U.
G.
I don't know what that means,
but a,
hey,
what's up person from China?
When I was training to,
uh,
get my pilot's licence,
I flew with a bunch of your countrymen who came over here,
barely spoke English and then learned how to fly helicopters.
One of the most amazing things ever because I don't think I could go to mainland
China.
Right.
Okay.
I think have an instructor.
My Buddy,
uh,
said to me,
I go,
they don't understand English.
How do you,
how do you communicate?
And he said,
they understand tone,
which is what I would understand if I was over there and this guy went
screaming.
I'll be all right.
All right.
Don't do what I just did.
Got It.
Um,
alright.
JFK files.
Oh,
Billy root beer float.
I love a root beer float.
I never get them cause I don't want to be a fat.
Fuck all the cowboys throw a pick six.
Wow.
Oh,
that wasn't it.
Was that a pick six?
No,
it wasn't.
They didn't throw a pick six.
That was actually an offensive play.
Why did that guy look like a cornerback to me?
Um,
okay.
As Kansas City going to do it to share everybody.
Okay.
Is Andy Reid finally going to bring a team to the promise land in a hoist the
trophy?
It's up in the air this year.
Um,
which once again,
you look how bad the fucking giant,
sir.
I don't understand how you have a coach,
how you have a GM,
how you have these guys in place that got you trophies,
trophies,
Superbowl,
plural,
and you get rid of them.
It's like the Red Sox with fucking Theo Epstein and uh,
you know,
fucking Terry Francona.
We get rid of those guys.
And then literally there's a world series with Theo Epstein's cubs and Terry
Francona is fucking Indians last year I,
I,
you know,
I still don't understand it.
It's almost like morning radio.
Like morning radio is another thing that I watch and I just see these great
shows and the two hosts end up inevitably hating each other.
Then the great show goes away.
And I'm not just talking about the one that I did,
it happens all the time.
And I think that that's just what happens.
It's nobody's fault.
It's just,
yeah,
I dunno.
The same way.
You know,
after a while you like,
even though you have shirts,
you want a new shirt.
I think people do that with like relationships.
And that's what's so fucked up about marriage is it said same God damn shirt.
And as much as you're looking at your wife go,
and that's that same old shirt.
You got to understand you're a fucking old shirt too.
All right?
And the two of you have to hold on to each other until God takes you to
goodwill.
Um,
alright.
JFK.
So stupid.
All right.
Jfk files old Billy root beer float.
Oh God damn.
And I love a root beer float.
I'm sure you've,
you have heard that,
that the JFK files or some of them had been released and as a fellow conspiracy
theorists,
I thought this might interest you to,
they're not gonna release anything.
If somebody else really did it and they actually know who did it,
then not to be like,
all right,
I think it's safe to tell you that the guy who really did it was not named Lee
Harvey Oswald,
his name was Larry fucking whatever,
the Larry Fellowship.
Um,
and one of the files,
the CIA states that it planned bombings in Miami to kill innocent people so that
they can blame it on Fidel Castro.
Now that there is undeniable proof that the CIA isn't above killing innocent
innocence to get their way.
Does that change your views on any other conspiracy theories?
I know how much you suck at reading.
So I attached the link with the actual snippet of what I'm talking about.
Um,
yeah,
I mean I,
I'd have to see that that was,
you know,
you know what's interesting,
I just clicked on that and all of a sudden I'm not,
I'm not hooked up to the Internet.
How weird is that?
I was hooked up into the Internet and start until I tried to look at this
fucking thing.
Now I basically taking your word that that's actually what happened.
If that is in fact the case.
Okay.
We could develop a communist Cuban terror campaign in the Miami era and other
Florida cities and even Washington,
the terror campaign could be pointed at Cuban refugees
seeking haven in the United States.
We could sync a boatload of Cubans in route to Florida real or simulated
what the fuck,
real or simulated.
In other words,
they own enough.
They could just say it happened and how do people know it did,
we could foster attempts on lives of Cuban refugees in the United States even to
the extent of wounding in instance.
Okay.
What,
even to the extent of wounding and instances to be a,
to be widely publicized,
exploding a few plastic bombs and carefully chosen spots also seen sound like
they're going to fucking kill fellow Americans.
I think that they're going to kill Cuban refugees here.
Um,
exploding a few plastic bombs and chuck carefully chosen spots.
The rest of Cuban agent and the release of prepared documents substantiating
Cuban involvement also would be helpful in projecting the idea of an
irresponsible government.
Um,
yeah.
None of that's surprising.
I mean,
is that really surprising?
If you just sort of fucking pay attention and just even just even remotely try
to read between the lines.
Um,
yeah,
we're not as good as we act like we are,
but I'm also not going to then glorify Fidel Castro like he was just fucking
saint.
But,
uh,
you know,
I don't think it's crazy to say that,
we were more upset
with Fidel Castro,
not because he was,
you know,
a communist was probably more because he wouldn't let us develop his country the
way we saw fit.
And by we,
I don't mean the average fucking person walking down the street.
I'm talking about the corporations and I don't think that that policy has
changed.
And I'm not going to get on a fucking stump here,
but I don't think that that has changed at all.
And,
uh,
and currently that philosophy as bankrupted this country and I don't know what's
going to happen.
And that's all really heavy shit.
And I,
you know,
I remember reading something that j Edgar Hoover allegedly said,
even if they do figure it out,
it's so fucking overwhelming and depressing.
They won't want to think about it.
And that's where I get to.
So I just go to Milwaukee and I get a brat and I have a good time and I be the
dancing monkey that I am.
And I just hope that the lie is able to sustain itself.
I Dunno.
I Dunno what the fuck to do.
Yeah.
So that's great.
So that's why I kind of backed away from conspiracy theory because,
um,
cause you don't want to be right
even remotely.
Um,
so anyways,
let's get out of that.
Oh,
let's,
let's talk a robot granted citizenship.
Oh my God.
Out of the frying pan into the fire.
I would love to read the a declassified CIA file on fucking what the hell they
plan to do with robots.
I mean,
there's no fucking way that they're not talking.
Like I always joke how they never discussed the population problem.
They absolutely fucking do,
but not to the general public because it would freak them out.
Because I think at that point you realize how overpopulated we are and how,
uh,
expendable you are.
I mean,
that's how I would feel.
You know,
how many stand up fucking comedians?
I mean for the survival of humanity.
Do you really need another one?
Yeah.
MMM.
All right.
Robot.
Granted citizenship.
Uh,
greetings from Austin.
You were literate piece of shit.
All right.
Well,
hello.
Hello to you and your fucking overpopulated fucking city.
Uh,
keep it weird.
It shouldn't keep it.
We should keep it weird by fucking preventing more people from moving to that
great place and ruining it.
Uh,
I ran across the,
uh,
I ran across this the other day and thought of your podcast.
They gave a robot citizenship.
Her name is Sophia,
and she was acknowledged as a citizen in Saudi Arabia.
You know what?
That's fucking great.
Because what they just did was they ended their country.
That's over.
The second is a robot is,
becomes a citizen.
That is beginning.
That is the beginning of the fucking end.
Beginning of the fucking end of your goddamn a way.
Was that a special teams?
Fucking touchdown.
I Dunno what's going on.
Anyways,
uh,
that's the beginning of the end of your country.
And considering from what I've read,
that these terrorist groups for the most part are funded through Saudi Arabia,
sending money,
funneling them through mosques.
Uh,
I think that'd be a good thing.
You know.
Now if we could just stop trying to build Starbucks over there and just fucking
come home,
you know,
just walk away from it instead of being that degenerate gambler sitting at the
fucking black Jack table waiting for the cards to turn around.
Um,
all right,
so they did this,
not exactly the best spot for a female human.
Oh,
Saudi Arabia.
Uh,
maybe they will be nicer to robots.
Okay.
This is scary how God damn creepy is that thing.
I know this will freak you out,
Bill.
Just fast forward to any point where the robot is talking.
Yeah,
I watched it.
You guys got to see this video.
And I love how the journalist asks,
acts like he's asking these hard hitting fucking questions as if these questions
weren't written out for this fucking sellout human piece of shit,
which is what you have to say now,
this human sold out other humans to this non fucking human life form.
What the fuck are we doing?
He actually says,
well,
how do we know that we could trust you?
Or something like,
how do we know you're not going to blah,
blah,
blah.
Like just like a stuck a comedy team just lobs this setup over and then the
robots,
like you're watching too much.
Elan Musk and Hollywood movies.
Okay.
And then like,
oh,
it made a joke.
Oh,
I see.
It's friendly.
It's like,
it's not a person.
It doesn't have a heart.
It doesn't have a fucking soul that is a programmed fucking response.
All right.
And they're going to have to have all these facial expressions to make you feel
fucking comp.
MMM.
That is a,
that thing is,
is our replacement,
without a doubt.
Without a doubt.
And,
uh,
I definitely think the robots are gonna kill us.
I don't think they're literally maybe going to kill us,
but I think they will kill us off the way the car killed off.
You know,
the horse is a mode of transportation,
which was probably cool for the horse because he's probably sick of us being on
his back.
Right.
But I don't think it's gonna be cool for us because we will become obsolete.
We will be,
uh,
a,
the human version of a cassette tape
when all the kids,
when iPods and the kids will be basically whoever employs the CIA.
All right,
there we go.
Isn't this fun?
Isn't this fucking uplifting?
How about those Kansas City chiefs,
bread and circus.
All right.
Hot Girl and coffee shop.
I like the sound of this already.
Uh,
old Billy booze lists.
That's right.
Billy bootlace puzzles.
80 days.
We'll be 81 by the time you listen to this,
unless I go off the rails tonight.
I'm a big fan of your stand up and the podcasts all the way from Glasgow,
Scotland
all the way from Glasgow,
Scotland uh,
are cut to the chase.
Um,
Glasgow,
Scotland,
that's where,
um,
ACDC recorded there.
If you want blood live album
right
in a venue that doesn't exist anymore cause I tried to find it when I was over
there.
I'll cut to the chase.
I'm a 23 year old guy who was recently graduated from college and moved down to
London about five months ago to start a new job.
All right.
I am enjoying life in my new surroundings and the girls down here are of another
planet compared to back home.
However,
there is one,
there is one for in particular who has caught my attention and I'd like your
advice on the best way to ask her out.
The lovely knee,
his advice as welcome.
She probably have a better idea of what to do here than I would but she's not
here as,
I'm in Green Bay,
Wisconsin right now.
All right.
She works in a coffee shop near my work and she is immense.
Easily a 9.3 slash 10 I never have a problem with women,
but 90% of the time I have had a few beers in me at the time and my confidence
is at its peak.
Can you give me any advice on how to ask this girl out?
Giving that it's a small coffee shop in full view of the general public?
Uh,
we had some chat.
Oh,
that's good.
So I was going to say,
go in there and start talking to her and I'm 80% sure she's into me,
but I'm shitting myself in case I get the rejection and there's around 30 people
there to witness it.
Dude.
Fuck those other 30 people.
What you have at your fingertips is a great story.
No matter what happens,
you either possibly meet the love of your life,
right?
Settle down,
have kids together and live happily,
happily ever after.
Or You have a hilarious fucking story,
Dude.
Fuck that.
The worst she can say is no.
Who gives a shit?
Oh Dude.
I'd ask her out in the middle of the meal,
you know,
just to make the awkwardness even further.
Just steer.
Who gives a fuck.
Fuck that dude.
If you can chat up women,
it's not because you're drunk,
it's because you got rid of that stupid voice in your head that says that you
can't,
you obviously can't.
Alcohol doesn't make you talk to women.
All right?
It doesn't make you talk to women better.
What it does is it gets rid of your fucking fear so you can actually,
you know,
perform.
This is like some fucking,
uh,
John Daly Shit.
Like he used to have a couple of courts lights so he'd relax more,
hit the ball further.
I'm not saying to go in there,
shit faced.
Okay.
Fuck.
I got to go back to this.
Kansas City touched on it was a pass.
Sorry.
Anyways,
yeah.
Dude,
I just go in there to fuck this.
You're the man.
She works in a coffee shop.
She's not splitting atoms.
All right.
Just go in there.
Just go in there,
build.
You just not even like fucking try to walk in like you're the man.
He's some bad ass dude.
Just fucking like block out that voice.
Anytime you that voice,
it's going to go great.
Make her laugh.
You don't want,
when she said I would that be all,
just ask Jessica for a number.
Do you know you should ask fucking Joe to Rosa.
One time I was with Joe de Rosa.
You want to talk about guy fearless?
I was with Joe to rose and one time we went out to breakfast and the waitress
came over,
you know,
and uh,
he's Kinda checking her out or whatever and we fucking eating.
We were eating her food and he goes,
when you think of that waitress,
I'm like,
she's cute.
He goes,
yeah.
I think I'm going to ask her out.
And she comes back to the table.
It's like,
will that be all any fucking asked her out right in front of me.
Right.
And she gave him his number.
Now if she shot him down,
not only it's like that story would have left.
It's like either would just be like with you,
with a bunch of strangers.
I could've sat there and laughed at him,
which I wouldn't have.
I wouldn't have laughed at him,
but he maybe he would have thought that I did and he didn't give a fuck.
So I think you go Joe,
to rose on this one.
All right.
Listen,
what is the deal?
You're attracted to her.
You want her number to ask her out.
All right,
so fucking do that.
That's what you want.
This the same way you handle your career in life.
What do you want to do?
Go do that.
Who Do you want to be with?
You know that's a different thing cause they have a say but you got to ask.
That's it.
So I dunno.
I Dunno what your deal is.
If you're a funny guy,
whatever your deal is,
I don't know.
Whatever you're doing,
it seems to be working cause you get feeling a vibe like she's India.
All right,
so just stop listening to that voice going like Boomi.
Yeah.
Well yeah,
you did say,
Hey,
what happens if she says yes.
Think about that.
All right,
there you go.
Alright.
Mixed race relation.
Jesus cry.
A lot of people think I'm an expert on this just because you know
it's lily.
If I fell off a bed.
Hey Bill,
you just,
you fell off a Beto.
I need some advice on fallen off a bed.
I don't know how the hell I ended up in this relationship.
I just met her and I liked her.
I asked her out in and out.
I couldn't get rid of her.
I didn't want to get rid of every time I ever thought about breaking up with her
when I was be like,
all in a panic of Holly.
Fuck,
I'm in here with him for three months now.
My God,
the pressure,
all this pressure was building up on myself.
I would always picture her walking out of my apartment.
Then even in the fantasy of getting out of the relationship,
I would always run out to go back and get her.
And then it took me about a good hour,
seven,
eight years to realize bill.
That means because you love her and you don't want her to leave.
Um,
all right.
Hey Bill,
you fuckin alabaster bastard,
alabaster bastard.
You Alabaster.
Why did you do that?
Hey Bill,
you fucking alabaster.
Uh,
I'm also a white guy who has just started going out with a smoking hot black
chick.
I have no idea what she sees in me,
but who gives a fuck?
Right?
She makes me happy and I seem to be happy.
Make her happy too.
So it's all good until you go outside.
Uh,
so one of my question is someone who's in a successful quote mixed race.
I don't know why it's in quotes,
mixed race relation.
I wonder if you have any insights or Gotchas that might help my relationship
list,
make my relationship last.
And do you still experience any casual racism from the mouth breathing morons?
Uh,
I'll spell check this message and be careful to use correct punctuation too.
So Billy,
if you do read it,
you won't sound like a preschool toddler auditioning for sesame street.
Thanks for the podcast.
I listen to them every week and go fuck yourself.
I love how the punctuation is my fault.
Still.
It's still my fault.
I'm the victim.
MMM.
Do have any insights.
Uh,
yeah,
this is my insight is that,
uh,
youtube people are different than me and my wife because you're an individual.
All right?
So I,
you know,
it's not like wow,
when like,
it's like when you watch the discovery channel,
well,
when dealing with the hippopotamus,
there's an aggressive behavior when it's fucking partly cloudy.
Um,
uh,
my advice is if you're with somebody and they make you happy,
stay with them.
They don't break up with them.
That's it.
All right?
And if you're in that situation right now and you want to break up with
somebody,
don't use the holidays as an excuse.
All right?
Just get out now.
I actually tell you it's better to do it right before the holidays then after.
Okay.
Cause as much as you're gonna fuck up at Thanksgiving,
Christmas,
Hanukkah,
Kwanzaa,
uh,
the new year comes and with the new year they'd be like,
you know,
I'm going to go to the job,
which is going to get,
forget about it.
It was the worst year ever.
You know,
if you fucking wait till after the holidays and then boom,
they're year starts.
He just fucked up their whole next year.
Cause people think in calendar years for whatever reason.
All right,
so getting back to you,
um,
I mean,
what do you want me to say?
Let's start listening to the,
to fucking Jay Z.
MMM.
I will tell you this,
when it comes to that Shit,
uh,
there is uh,
still stay in your own lane kind of thing.
MMM.
Just cause you're with her,
don't start saying,
uh,
don't start using the expression.
Ah,
this still,
you know,
I guess I can't give you a voice.
There are things like that.
There are things like that that no matter how much she loves you,
you will immediately turn into it and annoying white person.
And yes,
racism doesn't magically go away because the two of you are now together.
But I will be honest with you,
it's just like if it wasn't racism it would be something else.
Um,
you know,
I kept talking about Chicago and Milwaukee and they kept blowing Chicago.
They didn't like Chicago.
So it's like people,
people don't like their next door neighbors.
They don't like the people they work with.
You know,
football teams don't like coaches and gms,
that one,
them super bowls.
So if it,
if it wasn't that,
it will be something else.
And who gives a shit what other people think?
You only go around once and you should be with the person you're supposed to be
with.
That's what I think.
All right,
so have fun.
Enjoy yourselves.
And uh,
that's it.
All right,
first breakup.
Hey,
Billy,
Pink Dick.
I don't know what this,
that some cancer thing,
uh,
been listening to your podcast.
I don't know what that means,
but that's funny as hell.
But listening to your podcast for a couple of years now and could really use
your advice.
I'm a 22 year old college senior and recently have gone through a breakup.
Uh,
that's great.
He got it done before the holidays,
so she got it done.
We dated for six months and it was great.
She was my first girlfriend and my first love.
She was even the first girl I ever had sex with our right.
See,
not checked it all off,
but as we neared six months,
I began to worry about committing to a longterm relationship when I've never
even had sex with another woman.
Uh,
my dick got cold feet and rightly so.
Rightly so,
because as a guy,
if you're thinking that shit,
you're going to eventually do it.
So why harder?
Anyway,
so long after,
so after a long talk,
we decided to break up.
I thought having sex for the first time was tough,
but breaking up for the first time it was horrible.
Yes it is.
I can't seem to get out of this funk.
It's really hard not to miss her.
What advice do you have for someone going through their first breakup?
My friends and I have gone to a bar only once or twice since,
and none of us have any game.
We stand around the corner of the bar looking like mere cats.
That's hilarious.
It's the last quarter of the game and I'm down 10 points.
I could use a motivational speech from coach Ginger pubes over here.
Thanks.
And Go fuck yourself.
Uh,
all right.
We obviously have a sense of humor.
Um,
he has to deal to,
uh,
my advice when you're going through a breakup is rather than doing the guy thing
and trying to block it out,
like it isn't happening,
go through the sadness of it all.
Right?
Don't cry in front of your friends,
but if you got to cry,
cry it audience,
it's actually a healthy thing.
Crying is a healthy emotion.
I finally figured that out.
You know,
when I haven't cried enormous 50 fucking years.
So now it's like no longer,
like,
I dunno,
it's like a room that I walled off.
I mean,
literally a friend of mine has to die.
I have to be at a fucking funeral,
you know what I mean?
MMM.
But anyways,
I don't run from the pain of it.
Okay?
Okay.
That's what women do.
Women when they fucking break up,
they don't fucking run right off for the most part.
They don't run right out and get into something else.
They stay home.
They watch sad movies.
They listened to sad fucking,
uh,
they listen to sad.
Oh my God.
The chiefs just did a potato sack race,
celebration,
dance.
I was actually rooting for them to share.
I was like,
yeah,
it'd be cool to see them,
but maybe when it,
you know,
the Patriots hours mediocre is they look
okay
and uh,
I got to say fuck that whole franchise
if not the whole state.
I'm glad the Saint Louis cardinals moved.
I'm even going to take St Louis now.
That was the,
it's one of the worst things I've ever seen.
Now of course,
show it again.
Why
if we were willing to Dunkin contest when people just out of ideas,
so just,
it's enough already.
Just spike the ball like Gronk and go back to the sideline.
Oh boy.
Oh Jesus.
I got to walk that one off.
You know when you got a Kevin like a fucking separate meeting with,
for the teammates to get your end zone dance together.
I may just,
I dunno.
Anyways.
Yeah.
What women do correctly is they,
they,
when they're sad,
they allow themselves to be sad.
If they have to cry,
they allow themselves to cry and you actually feel better after you do that
stuff.
It's when you ignore it and you push it down,
it becomes his fucking weight in your chest or these fucking ball of shit in
your head.
Um,
okay.
You broke up with somebody and you're sad.
So I would be sad.
And then as far as going out to a bar,
um,
you know,
I mean,
I don't know,
how do you learn how to throw a football?
It's the first time you throw a football if you don't throw a tight spiral,
do you just never throw one again.
You keep doing it and it gets better.
You got to go out there and uh,
we used to fucking we amen.
We just go to his place.
Daisy Buchanan said,
I guess was a legendary meat market on Newbury street in Boston and
we used to,
we used to just fucking,
you went in there like,
it was almost like a standup comedy thing where you just went up in like
deliberately tried to bond to make your friends laugh.
We used to go in there and just any dumb fucking thing we could think of as we
just kept doing it and doing it and doing it right.
And it did,
it stopped being the way we got over the fear,
because it is the fear of rejection.
It's fucking brutal when you're young.
Right?
So we did is we would hit on some chick while our other buddy could hear it.
So if you started bombing and she wasn't in it,
you could then just switch over to try to make your friend laugh by making even
more of a fool yourself.
And then all of a sudden,
rejection became funny.
It didn't become this like,
oh my God,
is there something wrong with me?
I want to run out of here.
Uh,
dude,
you're young.
You're 22 years old,
you know?
Yeah.
I,
I don't even know how to say it.
It's just like I would hit on every cute chick you saw.
You know,
I'm not saying to go out there and be a fucking man whore,
but you're single and
I mean,
college life,
that's like the greatest fucking nightclub ever.
Everybody's single.
Everybody's young and good looking.
I mean,
there's no reason.
That's not the time to be shy.
Get over your shyness and just fucking throw it out there and said,
who gives a fuck?
Gives a shit
we're saying is that they say no and he'd keep coming back and be fucking times
I bombed before I got to this level of being able to do my shit and Dick Jokes.
Um,
all right.
Anyways.
Oh God.
Now they're just going to keep showing the potato sack.
They've shown it like three fucking times.
Um,
anyways.
Well,
and you know what?
I'm not,
I'm not going to be the crabby old man.
Good for those guys and I'm going to keep rooting for the Kansas City chiefs
cause I know there's long die hard fans.
They got that fucking great stadium.
Uh,
I walked it off and just say,
you know what pill the NFL continues to change in.
A new generation has come in and this is how they celebrate touchdowns and don't
be the grumpy old man.
Then you should just get the ball back to the ref.
I'm not going to be that guy.
All right,
great.
Let's see a three legged race next.
All right.
God bless him.
God bless them.
God bless Dj Music.
Yeah.
God bless the CIA in whatever they're doing with the robots.
All right.
That's the podcast for this week.
Um,
go fuck yourselves and I will check in on you on Thursday.
I'm going to upload a pictures of some of the shit that I did in a Milwaukee
and,
uh,
some of the Harley Davidsons and all that type of shit.
And I know there was something else.
Oh,
the Pfister hotel,
the unfortunately named Pfister hotel.
Um,
I'll,
I'll upload all of that shit.
All right.
That is it.
I'll talk to you later.